alors
qu'il souhaite commencer
[Musique]
monsieur ben qu'est-ce que vous erice sa
15 secondes avant langage alors pourquoi
le blanc
génial
les super héros
ne devrait pas exister
j'ai bien l'intention de finir ce que
j'ai commencé
[Musique]
le monde entier est en plein chaos
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
par où commencer
non
ok c'est un plan
faut savoir si besoin les mêmes
[Applaudissements]
tu t'es fait éclater par une collégienne
[Musique]
vous voyez c'est pas si difficile
ouais une seconde à quoi vous jouez à
celui qui baissera les yeux prônons
lumier cligner des yeux consternant
dents mais quel âge vous avez
[Musique]
excuse moi pas de problème jeune homme
vous suivez mon deuxième coup rossi
ouais non c'est non et
[Musique]
c'est la première fois que je te vois
comme ça l est pas comme les autres tu
peux pas comprendre on a tous un lien à
quelque chose d'incroyable il est il ya
moindre chose que je puisse faire pour
vous pourriez me tenir la main vous ne
perdez pas de temps vous
intéressant céline
bush qui perd bientôt comment je me sens
déjà très proche de toi je plus grand
soin c'est par sow
c'est sûr que tu sauras joueront je
crois que je serai jerry
[Musique]
rice
aurait
je t'en supplie
à peu près 2% de la population à ce
genre de soucis compte tenu de vos
antécédents médicaux nous ne sommes pas
optimistes si tu ne m'as pas pour toi je
te demande de te battre pour
qu'est ce que tu vas faire avec la
nouvelle liberté je préfère vivre le
moment présent avec toi je crois au fait
que le lien est partout dans la
gentillesse d'un accueil et dans l'amour
de votre famille
[Musique]
au fait que chacun d'entre nous à un but
même si on ne le voit pas
j'ai fait ce rêve incroyable
d'avoir la meilleure équipe qui existe
est de réaliser l'impossible
[Musique]
devenir champion olympique
très chers camarades vous allez
travailler avec un nouvel entraîneur
c'est quoi ça c'est mon équipe
je marque en moyenne 30 points par match
qui d'autre fait ça
les russes vous comprenez jamais rien
tu fais combien 100 m en 7 tu peux faire
beaucoup mieux que ça
c'est pas avec des choix aveugle que je
vais gagner
dit rien à personne sinon ils vont virer
de l'équipe
est-ce que tu marques souvent visibles
non pas trop et auto thriller pas
souvent la balle bah oui c'est vrai que
tu comprends non eh ben tu vas
comprendre nous voulons battre les
américains
tu dis souvent que c'est impossible je
vais tout faire pour qu'on arrive à
débattre
[Applaudissements]
tu vas rencontrer toutes sortes d'ennuis
gagnant remporte la médaille d'or mais
les perdants ont bien plus à perdre que
la première place
peut-être qu'on ne devrait pas jouer
cet espoir c'est tout ce que nous
possédions
je te que vous jouiez selon n'aurait pas
les mêmes
[Musique]
les soviétiques n
tant qu un souffle de vie on peut tout
faire nous faisions partie de la même
équipe
certains fermiers achètent leurs graines
des grandes compagnies chaque année pour
les planter moi je garde les miennes
c'est comme ça que je travaille je
conserve mes craquer premier canola qui
arrive cette année c'est un sacré somme
est ce que tu en dis combien ça t'a
coûté tout ça tout investissement un
colis pour monsieur percy schmeiser
rabat doit y avoir une erreur
j'aimais propre gré
monsanto prétend que le canola que vous
avez cultivées en 97 présenter une
modification génétique créé par monsanto
ils sont déjà passés c'est qui ces gens
tapis monsanto va soutenir que toutes
ces graines sont sa propriété et bien le
tribunal tranchera
monsieur schmeiser avez vous déjà acheté
le canola de monsanto non monsieur
schmeiser rebecca salle co2 citoyens
pour la protection de l'environnement il
y a des milliers de personnes qui
veulent vous soutenir notre message
circule ils disent que j'ai cultivé le
canola de monsanto sans acheter la
licence tout mon travail le labeur de
toute ma vie leur appartient ce point
qu'on fonctionne et pour avoir fait ce
que ma famille a toujours fait depuis
des centaines d'années c'est la une du
washington post c'est formidable un
million deux cent mille dollars c'est la
somme que vous leur devez voilà ce qui
se passe quand on a recours aux avocats
nous allons perdre la ferme pour ces
données de cette propriété à la ferveur
on n'a pas besoin qu'il calme on a juste
besoin qu'ils continuent de se battre
c'est pas bien la télé de faire appel à
la cour suprême c'est ce que vous avocat
vous ont conseillé je n'ai pas encore
prévenu
avoir porté notre réponse jusqu'au plus
haut tribunal il ya beaucoup de fermiers
dans le monde tous n'ont pas les moyens
de se battre j'ai pensé que je devais
faire il s'agit d'une simple affaire de
violation brp si vous gagnez plus haut
qu'un fermier ne pourrait être poursuivi
pour avoir conservé ses graines ce qu'il
faut est témoin et on ne peut pas les
laisser faire il fallait se battre
[Musique]
ouais
ok je crois en est on se vit
comme moi elle n'arrête pas de donner
des coups de pied et va bien
une idée de comment on va sortir d'ici
je crois pas qu'on devrait sortir ça
ressemble pas vraiment un plus on va
geler l'attend mais tu crois pas qu'on
va geler l'adorent
et la lumière fut j'ai juste besoin que
tu fasses confiance d'accord démarrer
mais c'est en bout la fsu
je vais pisser sur une serviette il fait
plus en plus froid je sais qu est ce qu
on voit quand tu auras plus rien à
manger on se base des forces
on doit casser une fenêtre c'est de la
folie dit la police essaie de se balader
dans la nature sauvage et je les
écoutais
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui s'passe série
qu'est ce qui diffère
floride en fait tu veux que je lui tape
dessus des droits de m
t
[Musique]
bon vous savez pourquoi vous êtes là si
j'ai bien compris vous cherchez des
choristes pour duke sterling alors vous
allez faire quoi
c'est faux c'est
super a déjà mais j'en ai préféré
d'autres si vous voulez non ça ira merci
[Musique]
oui tout va bien pas passer si juste que
tu me manques essayez un laminaire
annonce en revanche si vous essayez pas
ça risque pas de marché
veuillez pas un trio à chinatown
[Musique]
mon nom ces crédits qu'au nord je pense
que vous avez beaucoup de talent
j'aimerais entendre
tu m'étonnes
[Musique]
ce type a écrit des chansons pour tous
les artistes de contrer auquel tu
pourrais penser y compris duc staline
c'est comme ça vous accueillez les gens
à silverado je suis pas prêt de partir
je peux chanter je veux écrire des
chansons et je veux qu'on écoute ce que
j'aime
musique et super texte il pourrait être
plus personnel vous pourrez faire une
chanson donc sujette à la quête de
l'amour je veux dire on sait que le
grand amour et quelque part mais qu'on
n'a pas encore trouvé la bonne personne
je te pose en challenger si vraiment ils
prêteront ma famille est propriétaire du
ranch où aura lieu le festival solidays
demande de chanter au festival samedi
soir avec un guide sur la grande scène
est ce que vous pensez de la proposition
que dieu fait à shane à deux chantiers
vécu c'est génial j'arrive
à compter sur scène tu es plus la même
personne enfin je veux dire celle qui
est la personne n'a envie de voir la
vraie mois
une chanson ça vient du coeur quel que
soit l'endroit où du produit
cette robe que par avis
dis pas que tu crois qu'il ya quelque
chose entre mois youtube
je vois pas un qui soit meilleur culte
et entre nous t'as pas besoin de dieu
couple rentre
oui
[Musique]
je suis ici pour le globe j'écris un
article sur l'opération goliath vous
avez le choix de me dire ce qui s'est
vraiment passé ou alors vous pouvez
gaspiller cette précieuse opportunité
je ferai bien attention avant d'imprimer
quoi que ce soit en rapport avec cette
affaire sinon quoi je ne voudrais pas
vous bis
cette opération est un scandale national
la police canadienne semble avoir
restera mon accent
certitude
oui ce ne peut pas publier cet article
ce pourrait ne revenir plus fort je vais
écrire mon [ __ ] d'articles tu peux le
mettre en première page au nom cdi temps
lightfoot
[Applaudissements]
tu penses pas qu'il est temps de laisser
tomber
thierry savent faire pour ça mon style
si jamais ce qui s'est passé ici été
rendu public
le canadien patrick
rien faire pour empêcher sa victoire tu
peut pas sauver la revente
[Musique]
tu veux que je fasse quoi que je laisse
pourrir en payant
[Musique]
j'ai mon exposé à faire enquête si tu
suis mon conseil tout ira bien mon père
dit que ça va bien se passer je
m'appelle angèle
mais je suis pas doué pour ça c'est mal
j'ai été un désastre
et tout à coup alors que tout allait on
ne peut plus mal j'ai développé un
pouvoir spécial refait mon lit et
arrange le reste du match qu'est ce qui
se passe mais le pouvoir d possédez vous
un kit une grande responsabilité pas le
faire quelque chose avec cela tu fais
quelque chose voudrais que tu demandes à
ce que je sois bon à cheval il arrête tu
peux faire des voeux qui se réalise tu
peux nous en dire plus c'est super
énervant de voir
après toi qui tu as raison je supporte
pas que ce soit moi qui décide pour une
fois charlie
j'aimerais avoir l'air aussi cool que
oui pourquoi je relis la bizarroïdes
hallucinant écoute amuse-toi bien
mashaei mais surtout fait attention ça a
marché
[Musique]
est-ce que je vous connais j'avais là où
on a besoin de moi
[Musique]
d
je savais de quoi quand je peux bien sûr
[Musique]
bien très bien